CONGRESS RELEASE THE MEMO AND
TELL US THE TRUTH AND THAT AND
MORE IN A VERY IMPORTANT OPENING
MONOLOGUE.
>>> OUR EXCLUSIVE REPORTING ON
THE DOJ.
WE CAN REPORT THE MISSING FBI
TEXT MESSAGES -- WE'LL TELL YOU
LETTING THE SPECIAL CROWN --
COUNSEL, ROBERT MUELLER, KNOW
THERE'S NO COLLUSION AND THERE'S
NOTHING TO HIDE.
>> I'M LOOKING FORWARD TO IT.
THERE'S BEEN NO COLLUSION
WHATSOEVER.
THERE'S NO OBSTRUCTION
WHATSOEVER AND I'M LOOKING
-- DO IT.
>> Sean: WITH HIS LAWYER'S
APPROVAL, THAT MAKES SENSE BUT
IS THAT THE SMART PLAY?
SOUND LIKE GAME ON TO ME.
THE DRUDGE REPORT HAS THE
HEADLINE UP AND SUMS IT UP
PERFECTLY, TRUMP STARES DOWN
MUELLER.
I'LL DO IT UNDER OATH.
AND WE'LL BE JOINED LATER WITH
LEGAL REACTION.
ALSO TONIGHT, THE WALLS ARE
CLOSING IN ON THOSE RESPONSIBLE
FOR THIS MASSIVE CORRUPTION
ABUSE OF POWER AT THE TOP LEVELS
OF GOVERNMENT IN WHAT WE'RE NOW
CALLING STATE-SPONSORED
SABOTAGE.
WITH THE FLOOD OF DAMNING NEWS
EXPOSING MALFEASANCE THEY WANT
US ON THE FOX NEWS CHANNEL FOR
DARING TO REPORT ON THE TRUTH.
FOR THOSE WANTING TO ADVANCE
FALSE NARRATIVES, WE NEVER HAVE
BEEN AND NEVER WILL WILL TALK
ABOUT RANK AND FILE MEMBERS OF
THE FBI, DOJ AND THE
INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY.
THEY'RE HONOR US WITH THEIR
SERVICE EVERY DAY AND THERE'S NO
SHOW ON TELEVISION THAT HAS AND
WILL CONTINUE TO SUPPORT THESE
HARD-WORKING PEOPLE THAT DO SUCH
A SERVICE TO THEIR COUNTRY.
WITH A FEW SELECT, OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION, TOP BUREAUCRATS
WHO THOUGHT THEY KNEW BETTER
THAN YOU DID ABOUT WHO SHOULD BE
YOUR PRESIDENT.
THE LIBERAL MEDIA IS ENGAGED IN
A TOTAL SMEAR CAMPAIGN AND THEY
WANT TO SHUT UP PEOPLE LIKE ME
AND GREGG JARRETT AND TOM FENTON
AND SO MANY OTHERS.
THEY WANT TO CONCEAL THE TRUTH.
NOW, WE'VE ALWAYS HAD THE UTMOST
RESPECT FOR THE FBI, I HAVE
FAMILY IN THE FBI AND
INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY AND
POLICE OFFICERS AND FIREFIGHTERS
AND MILITARY.
NOW, CAN THE LIBERAL MEDIA SAY
THE SAME FOR THEMSELVES?
WE KNOW THE ANSWER.
HOW MANY TIMES HAVE YOU HEARD
THEM ATTACK PEOPLE IN UNIFORM?
THOSE THAT SERVE US AS MUCH AS
THEY DO.
NOW THAT WE'RE GETTING CLOSER
AND CLOSER EVERY NIGHT IN
UNCOVERING THIS HUGE HISTORIC
MASSIVE SCANDAL, THE MEDIA IS
RUSHING TO SLANDER AND DISCREDIT
THOSE OF US EXPOSING THIS.
AT THE END OF THE DAY, EVERY ONE
OF THE SO-CALLED JOURNALISTS AT
THE SO-CALLED NEWS NETWORKS ARE
GOING TO LOOK LIKE THE FOOLS WE
ALREADY KNOW THEY ARE.
THE SAME PEOPLE WHO HAVE BEEN
CLINGING TO A SINK LIFEBOAT OF
THE PHONY TRUMP-RUSSIA COLLUSION
STORY.
IT'S BEEN A YEAR AND THEY STILL
CANNOT ADMIT THEY'VE BEEN WRONG.
THERE'S NO EVIDENCE AND IN MANY
INSTANCES THEY'RE FLAT-OUT
LYING.
SINCE NONE OF THIS HAS WORKED
THEY'RE DOING THE BIDDING OF
ROBERT MUELLER AND THE REPORTING
ON WHAT THE SPECIAL COUNSEL IS
NO LONGER JUST INCHING TOWARDS
THE PRESIDENT.
THIS MORNING, IT'S MORE LIKE
CAREENING.
>> HAPPENING NOW, BREAKING NEWS,
THE RUSSIA PROBE CLOSES IN ON
THE PRESIDENT AND HIS INNER
CIRCLE.
AFTER 24 HOURS OF BOMBSHELL
REPORTS AND ANOTHER JUST IN.
CNN HAS NOW LEARNED THE SPECIAL
COUNSEL, ROBERT MUELLER, WANTS
TO QUESTION THE FORMER WHITE
HOUSE STRATEGIST STEVE BANNON.
>> IT'S FILLING IN BIT BY BIT AS
THE POLITICAL TEAM NOTES IF THE
OPTICS AROUND THE MEETING WITH
LORETTA LYNCH WAS BAD, THIS IS
QUOTE A HUNDRED TIMES WORSE.
WAS A DAY OF REVELATION IN THE
RUSSIA PROBE.
>> IF THERE'S ANY DAY TO WATCH
IT'S TODAY, RUSSIA, RUSSIA,
RUSSIA.
>> Sean: ANYTIME THERE'S MASSIVE
NEWS ABOUT THE MASSIVE ABUSE OF
POWER ALL OF A SUDDEN THREE OR
WILD FIRE IN THEIR OWN ECHO
CHAMBER.
SO PREDICTABLE.
IT'S PAINFULLY OBVIOUS AND BY
THE WAY, A LOT OF THEIR
INFORMATION I BELIEVE WHEN IT'S
ALL SAID AND DONE, PROBABLY
COMING FROM ROBERT MUELLER AND
THE DEMOCRAT HACKS PUSHING THEM
THEMSELVES.
NOW, ALSO TONIGHT, BIG
DEVELOPMENTS ABOUT THE EXPLOSIVE
CLASSIFIED MEMO EXPOSING FISA
ABUSES AGAINST THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN.
FOX NEWS IS REPORTING THEY'RE
NOW ASKING DEVIN NUNES TO NOT
PUBLICLY RELEASE THE MOMENTO WE
DESERVE.
NOW, DO THE DOJ NOT UNDERSTAND
THEY'RE INVESTIGATING THEM.
THEY DON'T HAVE TO HAND THE MEMO
OVER TO EVERYBODY IN SPITE WHAT
THE LIBERAL MEDIA SAYS.
WE'RE ONCE AGAIN CALLING ON YOU,
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE TO CALL UP
YOUR MEMBERS OF CONGRESS, DEMAND
THE MEMO BE RELEASED.
CALL THE NUMBER 202-224-3121.
ALSO BREAKING THIS HOUR, THIS IS
HUGE, NEW INFORMATION WITH THE
MISSING STRZOK/PAGE MESSAGES.
FIVE MONTHS, A CRITICAL PERIOD.
MULTIPLE SOURCES ARE TELLING ME
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE IS, AS
WE SPEAK, IN THE PROCESS OF
SUCCESSFULLY RECOVERING MANY OF
THE TEXT MESSAGES IN THE
FIVE-MONTH PERIOD OF TIME FROM
THE TRUMP-HATING FBI OFFICIALS
PETER
THEIR CELL PHONES TEXTS.
THIS IS CRITICAL.
HERE'S THE QUESTION, WAS ANDREW
McCABE'S CELL PHONE IMPACTED BY
THE SO-CALLED GLITCH?
HE WAS LISA PAGE'S BOSS.
BOTH SHE AND STRZOK TALKED
ABOUT, QUOTE, THE INSURANCE
POLICY IN THE OFFICE WE BELIEVE
WAS McCABE.
AND NEW REVELATION THE NEW
LAWYER REPRESENTING DISGRACED
FORMER FBI DIRECTOR AND SOON TO
BE INVESTIGATED JAMES COMEY.
ACCORDING TO BUZZ FEED ONE OF
HIS ATTORNEYS IS HIS COLUMBIA
LAW PROFESSOR BUDDY, THE GUY HE
LEAKED A MEMO TO "THE NEW YORK
TIMES" BECAUSE HE WANTED A
SPECIAL COUNSEL APPOINTED HIS
OTHER BFF, ROBERT MULE
OTHER BFF, ROBERT MUL
OTHER BFF, ROBERT MUEL
OTHER BFF, ROBERT MUELLE
OTHER BFF, ROBERT MUELLER.
YOU CAN'T MAKE THIS UP.
AND WE HAVE MOVE PROOF AND HE
TESTIFIED HE GAVE INFORMATION
AND BY THE WAY, THEY ALSO
COLLABORATE BEFORE HE TESTIFIED.
THE CLASSIFIED INFORMATION WAS
CREATED ON GOVERNMENT COMPUTERS.
SO COMEY BROKE THE LAW BY
REMOVING THEM THE FBI BUT IT'S
CLEAR MUELLER DIDN'T CARE ABOUT
ANY OF THAT.
THEY'RE BEST FRIENDS.
MUELLER'S MAIN FOCUS HAS BEEN
AND CONTINUES TO BE CARRYING OUT
A WITCH HUNT TO UNSEAT PRESIDENT
TRUMP.
IT'S AN ABOMINATION TO THE
NATION AND RULE OF LAW.
AS YOU HAVE SEEN WATCHING THE
SHOW THE PAST COUPLE OF NIGHTS,
THERE'S BEEN SO MUCH BREAKING
ALL OF THIS.
HIGHLIGHT A COUPLE VERY
IMPORTANT PIECES OF INFORMATION.
SENATOR RON JOHNSON REVEALING
WITH BRET BAIER LAST NIGHT AN
INFORMANT TOLD HIM THERE WAS
SOME SORT OF ANTI-TRUMP, QUOTE,
SECRET SOCIETY WITHIN THE FBI
AND HERE'S THE SPECIAL REPORT.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> WHAT THIS IS ALL ABOUT IS
THE HIGHEST LEVELS OF THE FBI.
THE SECRET SOCIETY, WE HAVE AN
INFORMANT TALKING ABOUT A GROUP
HOLDING SECRET MEETINGS
OFF-SITE.
THERE'S SO MUCH SMOKE AND
SUSPICIOUS.
>> STOP THERE.
A SECRET SOCIETY.
INFORMANT SAYING THAT?
>> YES.
>> IS THERE ANY MORE TO THAT?
>> WE HAVE TO DIG INTO THAT.
THIS IS NOT A DISTRACTION.
THIS IS BIAS POTENTIALLY
CORRUPTION AT THE HIGHEST LEVEL
OF THE FBI.
>> Sean: REALLY, SECRET SOCIETY?
YOU CAN'T MAKE THIS UP.
ABC NEWS IS OBTAINING IT AND
QUESTIONING IF IT'S A JOKE.
LISA PAGE WRITING PETER STRZOK,
ARE YOU EVEN GOING TO GIVE OUT
YOUR CALENDARS IT SEEMS DOUGH
-- DEPRESSING.
SENATOR JOHNSON IS MAKING NEWS
BY RELEASING TEXT MESSAGES FROM
HIGHLIGHTING THEIR FURTHER BIAS.
ON MAY 19 -- REMEMBER IT WAS
GONE DECEMBER 14 THROUGH THE
16th OF MAY AND THEN MUELLER WAS
APPOINTED AND ALL OF A SUDDEN
THEY STARTED REAPPEARING AGAIN.
STRZOK APPEARS TO BE TALKING
ABOUT GETTING AN OFFER TO JOIN
MUELLER'S INVESTIGATION.
THIS IS KEY, AND RIGHT HERE,
STRZOK, MY ANSWER IS NO.
AND THE LEAD DIVISION AND THEN I
THINK -- WAIT, A CASE WILL BE IN
MUCH LIKE YOU TELL ME ABOUT MY
EXTRA TIME IN THE FIELD AND ALL
THE CASES.
WOULD YOU TRADE IT?
A MILLION PEOPLE SIT ODD STAFF
JOBS -- I DIDN'T QUITE GET THAT,
THIS IS A CHANCE TO DO MAYBE THE
MOST IMPORTANT CASE OF OUR
LIVES.
BY THE WAY, THE SAME GUY SAYING
EARLIER THERE'S NO THERE-THERE.
30 MINUTES LATER STRZOK ADD ED
AN IMPEACHMENT AND HE TALKED
ABOUT THE POSSIBILITY OF
TRUMP/RUSSIA COLLUSION AFTER HE
WAS POINTED.
HE SAID YOU AND I BOTH KNOW THE
ODDS ARE NOTHING.
IF I THOUGHT IT WAS LIKELY, I'D
BE THERE MEANING WITH MUELLER.
NO QUESTION.
BIG THERE THERE.
WHY WOULD YOU WANT TO DO THAT?
SO STRZOK KNEW FROM THE
BEGINNING HE WAS LEADING A WITCH
HUNT AND HE WOULD KNOW BECAUSE
HE'S THE TOP INTELLIGENCE
OFFICIAL AND HE SIGNED THE
PAPERS TO START THE ENTIRE
RUSSIA INVESTIGATION.
STRZOK ALSO DROPPED THIS
BOMBSHELL FROM THE CLINTON
INVESTIGATION WRITING FOR ME AND
THIS CASE I HAVE A SENSE OF
UNFINISHED BUSINESS.
I UNLEASHED IT WITH MY -- WELL,
THE MIDYEAR EXAM, THE CODE NAME
FOR THE CLINTON INVESTIGATION.
NOW I NEED TO FIX IT AND FINISH
IT.
FIX IT AND FINISH IT?
STRZOK IS TEXTING THIS MAY 19.
REMEMBER, WHEN WE KNOW HILLARY
CLINTON WASN'T EVEN INTERVIEWED
UNTIL THE 4th OF JULY WEEKEND
ABOUT HER E-MAIL SERVER ON THE
4th OF JULY.
IT'S AT THIS POINT STRZOK AND
COMEY AND OTHERS WERE DRAFTING
THE EXONERATION BEFORE THEY
SPOKE TO CLINTON AND OTHER
WITNESSES AND STRZOK AND PAGE
TEXTED FOUR DAYS BEFORE COMEY'S
ANNOUNCEMENT AND BEFORE
INTERVIEWING HILARY AND CLINTON
AND LORETTA LYNCH ALL NEW
CLINTON WOULDN'T BE PROSECUTED.
IT'S SMOKE GUN EVIDENCE.
WHAT MORE DO YOU NEED?
STRZOK, COMEY, LORETTA LYNCH
THEY ALL KNEW THE FIX WAS IN.
IT WAS RIGGED.
LET ME CONNECT THE DOTS, HAVE
YOU HAVE DEEP-STATE ACTORS AND
TOP PEOPLE, STRZOK, PAGE, COMEY
AND LORETTA LYNCH AND ANDREW
McCABE SHIELDING HILLARY CLINTON
FROM PROSECUTION THOUGH IT IS
HER TO STAY IN THE RACE AND
DEFEAT IN THE ELECTION DONALD
TRUMP.
LANGUAGE WAS CHANGE FROM THE
LEGAL STANDARD NEGLIGENCE TO
EXTREME CARELESSNESS AND
SHELLING OUT FOR A SALACIOUS
DOSSIER FOR RUSSIAN PROPAGANDA
AND LIES TO RIG IT AGAINST
TRUMP.
SHE'S THE SAME WOMAN WHO RIGGED
THE PRIMARIES AGAINST BERNIE
SANDERS ACCORDING TO BRAZIL AND
FISA WARRANT.
THE PHONY RUSSIAN DOSSIER TO SPY
YEAR.
THEN AS A PRESIDENT-ELECT.
TALK ABOUT WATERGATE.
THIS IS WATERGATE ON STEROIDS ON
HUMAN GROWTH HORMONE.
THEAL
THEA
YOU HAVE DEEP-STATE ACTORS
ABUSING THE TOOLS OF
INTELLIGENCE WE GIVE THEM TO
PROTECT THE COUNTRY AND COVERING
UP HILLARY CLINTON'S CRIME
BECAUSE THEY WANTED HER TO STAY
IN THE RACE NOT BE INDICTED
BECAUSE THEY OUT TO THEY KNEW
BETTER THAN YOU WHO SHOULD BE
PRESIDENT.
MORE IMPORTANTLY, THEY THOUGHT
THEY WOULD NEVER GET CAUGHT.
THEY NEVER THOUGHT CLINTON WAS
GOING TO LOSE.
NOW TONIGHT, IT IS TIME FOR THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL, BY THE WAY,
GOOD JOB AT THE DOJ FINDING SOME
OF THE FIVE MONTHS OF MISSING
TEXTS AND I THINK THEY NEED TO
POINT A SECOND SPECIAL COUNSEL.
TO INVESTIGATE AND PROSECUTE